my former doctoral supervisor at cornell
just retired i just came back from
ithaca
but i saw the video you did with the
purple hair do you like that yeah it was
hot but there you are by the way i
received you can't imagine how many
letters from people from ithaca
telling me thank you so much i'm afraid
to open my mouth in ithaca wow and your
ability to satirize it is just
unbelievable
every single store every business every
car had blm
black transgender lives matter how how
many black transgender people exist four
right
so i mean so for i mean it's just
unbelievable right but that's the minds
the woke rabbit hole
nothing is as bad as ithaca which i hate
to say because cornell is where i was
trained i love ithaca you said and i
watched that the that segment that you
did
uh which i'm slightly turned out not
gonna lie um
you said look where's the wokest place
in the world and you kind of set a few
cities is it in berkeley or again is it
in oregon and then you're like nope
right where i went to college over here
in ithaca new york cornell brutal why is
it so bad there
so i
here's one supposition i think it
started off in the 60s as the super
let's all hug you know peace through
reggae music and you know that's that's
not crazy far from woodstock
exactly it's kind of the woodstock vibe
and then because it already has the the
ground for that kind of lovey-dovey
stuff then the walk parasites can come
in and then build on that so it becomes
this kind of beautiful melange of
hippie stuff with woke stuff and
everybody is transgender everybody has
blue blue you know pink hair and so on
it's just it's unbelievable it really is
it almost feels like a caricature like a
satirical piece it's just unreal so
who's thanking you for pointing this out
so i i had a guy who owns a gym write to
me and by the way if they're listening
to this all the people who wrote to me
my apologies if i don't write back i do
read all your messages i always feel so
guilty when people take the time to
write it's busy guys let me come here
give a little break here but i you know
once a month i will send out a grand
apology to everyone because i didn't
respond but i do read those messages so
i've got all kinds of people a guy works
at a coffee shop he's not woke but he's
afraid to say he's not work a guy who
owns a fitness center in ithaca
all kinds of people who said to me
you know we watched your clip and you
know i give them kind of a
a
a rope to sanity right because you start
wondering whether because you're not
woke but everybody around you whether
there's something wrong with you and
then here comes the blue a pink or what
is it
a purple haired professor who's who's
able to have the guts to make fun of
these things
and then they suddenly feel sane again
that there's you know this imprimature
of a professor who is agreeing with them
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]